this episode is presented by verizon
america's most reliable network is going
ultra
[Music]
from the company that distributes hbo
max content in theaters and one of the
minds behind jupiter ascending now bees
are genetically designed to recognize
royalty
comes an installment so long in the
making this is what technology looked
like when the last one came out freeman
713 i am a sentinel
the matrix resurrections
prepare for a film that asks the
ultimate question do you take the blue
pill and let them reboot this without
the creators starring tom holland as neo
or take the red pill and see how far up
its own ass this story can go this
cannot be another reboot retread
regurgitation why not i will sequel
franchise enough at last
i wasn't too sure about the callback but
you know it's just hard to resist as
matrix4 attempts the rare reverse double
mind
a movie about being forced to make a
follow-up to a trilogy you're currently
watching the forced follow up to which
just ends up being reality our beloved
parent company warner brothers has
decided to make a sequel to the trilogy
they informed me they're going to do it
with or without us it's like they
invented bulletin but for dodging
criticism
whoa
you forgot how the matrix ended
no the other ones look look
just look at that
pickup 60 years after neo became
computer jesus and brought an end to the
war between robot squids and cave ravers
and while in matrix coffees have become
extremely tiny not much has changed for
the billions still stuck inside
the matrix is the same or worse but nia
won't return to shut it down for good or
awaken the millions who still want to be
free no instead watch the chosen one
risk it all to eat his girlfriend if
there is a chance i can free her even if
it means endangering everyone in this
city because we're finally getting the
answer to what the franchise was really
about taking unlabeled pills then
risking it all to impress a girl you met
online
why do all my trinities look like harry
knowles
keanu reeves and his struggle beard
return as thomas anderson a game
designer who probably should have taken
over cyberpunk 2077 until he's reborn
again as neo again a living legend who's
treated with the reverence of a modern
day keanu reeves not uh fanboy out here
but this is kind of a huge moment for me
joining him is trinity who's back to
kicking ass and taking names two hours
into the run time
my name is trinity
there she is newcomer bugs the latest
example of warner brothers space jamming
their ips into everything my name is
bugs as in bunny what's up doc
a simulated version of morpheus because
the real one canonically died in the bad
2005 video game
can't bring back the best part of the
films if he died in a video game tie-in
that'd just be crazy niobi the character
from the good matrix video game tie-in
and i guess the sequels agent smith
who's been upgraded into a hot musical
theater actor but who brings as much
menace to the role as he did to king
george in hamilton awesome wow some
robo-scab class traders who all look
like these thingies and neil patrick
harris as the analyst a clear metaphor
for the fact that men do not need
therapy in fact i am the chosen one and
that married woman i'm obsessed with
does love me she just doesn't know it
yet okay i did my own research
you loved the first matrix for its
original mix of william gibson's
neuromancer with a gap khakis commercial
now all that meticulous craft will be
sidelined for the same quick-cut garbage
fighting that's numbed us out for the
last decade
augmented by effects that are supposed
to look fake and bad i guess and where
neo still knows kung fu but at this age
he'd just rather spam the block button
come on you have john wick in your movie
and that's the director of john wick
would it kill you to wick it up a bit
wiki wiki kiki kiki
so gather the adult children you've had
time to raise since the matrix came out
and revisit a film stuffed with about
100 references to a timeless classic
free your mind
anderson
time is always against us
etc etc and two or three references from
the sequels in this self-aware shrug of
defiance towards franchise filmmaking
that got trounced at the box office
because two rival studios released six
different spider-mans starring three
different actors then reunited them on
screen before the m4 tricks could even
come out sorry neo you're too late we've
all been spider-pilled
starring
it's about ethics and gaming symbolism
deus ex mac on her yeah yeah i know i'm
not lawrence fishburne but give me a
chance the defenders antivirus dark
clippy
you know weaving whoa is that christina
ricci for one scene jada packet smith
and when you finally buy a bidet i got a
hack in the bathroom hurry yes
the great trend robbery
pretty cool that the two big villains
are both musical theater icons when are
we getting the matrix on broadway
kristin chenoweth is the oracle that guy
who played shrek as the architect oh and
ben platt is the spoon kid he's the
perfect age
this episode is presented by verizon
america's most reliable network is going
ultra
we don't talk about bruno no no no
save the cheerleader save the world
kids this is the story of how i met your
mother
thank you for being a friend